Encryption the best way to keep people
from reading your email short of making
a subject line forward forward forward
forward hilarious joke from uncle Walter
no one's reading that you may not think
about encryption much but it is pretty
fundamental to all our lives almost
everything you do today uses a code
every time you log on to an internet
service like Twitter or Facebook and
send your password every time you log
into internet banking all of that
information is protected using
encryption code that's right
encryption can protect the things most
important to us our financial
information health records dick pics
trade secrets classified government
records dick pics
our physical location the physical
location of our dicks credit card
information dick pics and pictures of
our dicks and and it's not just our data
lots of things have computers in them
now even cars and last year to hackers
showed a writer from Wired how they
could disable his car on the interstate
do it kill the engine
so we're killing the engine right now I
turned on my hazard lights but I was
still stuck in the right lane with no
shoulder to escape onto he's panicking
yeah no he's panicking you killed
his engine on the freeway
don't hackers seem like they've played
so many video games they've forgotten
that cars are actual objects carrying
living people but while it can keep us
safe it's important to note encryption
also has a downside it's become so
ubiquitous it's making it impossible for
law enforcement to gain access to
certain information or as FBI director
James Comey puts it technology has
become a tool of choice for some very
dangerous people and unfortunately the
law has not kept pace with technology
and this disconnect has created the
significant public safety problem we
have long described as going dark yes
going dark
it's a deliberately ominous sounding
term because you wouldn't get so scared
if they just called it bad guy go
bye-bye
and you may have heard about this going
dark problem recently related to one
particular work iPhone belonging to Syed
Farook the San Bernardino gunman who
with his wife killed 14 people last
December the FBI needs Apple's help
because the security settings on the
phone locked the device if a password is
entered incorrectly too many times it
may even erase all the data on the phone
the FBI wants Apple to upload software
that lets its analysts get around the
security features and take as many shots
at the passcode is necessary yes the FBI
has a dead terrorist cell phone that
they cannot get into it's running a
newer version of Apple's operating
system where the data is fully encrypted
and can only be accessed by unlocking
the passcode even Apple can't currently
get into the phone so the government is
essentially demanding that they come up
with a cheat code for their top-selling
iPhone game what's my passcode rated E
for Everyone
Apple is currently fighting that order
in court arguing it shouldn't be forced
to undermine the security features that
protect its encryption an argument which
some have found troubling I think Apple
leadership risks having blood on their
hands how would the hell you can't
access a phone I just find baffling any
system that would allow a terrorist to
communicate with somebody in our country
and we can't find out what they're
saying is stupid wolf that is the
angriest Lindsey Graham has been about a
cell phone since his name got
autocorrected to linty grandma stupid
phone learn my name
I am your boss
stupid so dumb this this issue has even
been brought up on the campaign trail
with predictable results what I think
you ought to do is boycott Apple until
such time as they give that Security
number how do you like I just thought it
boy can't Apple oh I just love it
give me another one Israel Palestine I
make him wrestling those fake sumo
costumes done done being president is
easy but I will say this is a rare case
where Donald Trump's outrage is almost
understandable because Apple's refusal
to help crack a terrorist phone can seem
hard to defend especially when like John
Miller of the NYPD you think about it
incredibly simplistically there's no
bang there's no safe company there's no
fault
there is no apartment there's no door
that can't be penetrated with a lawful
order from the US Court okay point taken
but was penetrated to the best word
choice there the government needs to be
able to penetrate you at any time if we
feel you need penetration we have to be
able to penetrate you quickly and
effectively here and now why is everyone
getting so uptight about this but this
is not simple it's a hugely complicated
story with massive implications and once
we get to the end of it you may not feel
the same way that you do now because to
that man's point an encrypted phone is
not really like a bank or a safe if you
penetrate a safe you've only penetrated
that safe but a code to open a phone
could be modified to open many many more
phones a fact that does not escape Apple
CEO Tim Cook no one I don't believe
would want a master key built that would
turn hundreds of millions of locks even
if that key were in the possession of
the person that you trust the most that
key could be stolen the only way we know
to get additional information is to
write a piece of software that is the
software equivalent of cancer okay now
on one hand giving your phone cancer
sounds bad but on the other hand The
Fault in Our Stars would have been
amazing if shailene woodley was playing
a terminally-ill
iPhone 6s no god damn it
won't let you go hazel I'll hold down
the power button and the home button
simultaneously forever and to be clear
Apple hasn't been completely
uncooperative they've already given the
FBI the information they could access
including Farooq's iCloud backups from
about six weeks before the attacks but
they are refusing to create the
cancerous program the FBI wants not
because it can't be done they say it
would take six to ten Engineers up to
four weeks to do it or you know a
standard Genius Bar appointment but but
Apple worries that once they make that
program they can't keep it a hundred
percent safe and the FBI and its
supporters can be weirdly dismissive of
that issue in ways that indicate they
either don't fully understand how
technology works or are pretending not
to what the government is asking Tim
Cook is you designed it you can design
your way out of it for this one time if
you figure out the formula and crack
open this phone to the point that we can
then try codes against it you can tear
that formula up lots of cross it in the
fireplace and throw it away oh come on
you know Apple is not writing its code
on paper next to a fireplace they're a
cutting-edge technology company not Lord
Grantham and and as for the notion Apple
can throw the formula away after the FBI
uses it once nobody seriously thinks
that is going to happen Apple says if it
complies requests from law enforcement
could come for another phone an hour
later opening a Pandora's box
Apple officials pointed to the Manhattan
district attorney who says he has 175
iPhones with potential evidence from
serious crimes including murder that he
cannot open exactly there are over 175
other phones in line just in New York so
this is bound to set a precedent think
of the government as your dad if he asks
you to help him with his iPhone be
careful because if you do it once you're
gonna be doing it 14 times a day and
whatever happens in this case will have
ramifications because the FBI ultimately
wants Apple and the entire tech industry
to have its encryption always be weak
enough that the company can access
customer's data if law enforcement needs
it so it might be the iPhone today an
Android phone tomorrow
and to blackberry the day after that
assuming that the day after that is in
1998 and and you might be wondering but
look if there's a warrant do these
companies really have a choice to which
the answer surprisingly might be yes
they do the government is currently
citing the all writs Act of 1789 which
essentially mandates you must cooperate
with investigators if they ask you to do
something but courts are split over
whether it applies in cases like these
and there's not really any more recent
law covering this area which is not
entirely an accident because we have
been down this road before the
government grappled with encryption two
decades ago and in the early 90s they
even came up with what they thought
would be the ideal solution the
government will press private companies
to use a so called
Clipper Chip in their computers which
would allow authorities to monitor coded
messages now that clipper chip was
theoretically perfect your information
could be encrypted but the government
would have an access point when it
needed it it was like giving your house
key to a trusted neighbor you can trust
Mike he's only gonna try on your
underwear if it's absolutely necessary
there was just one problem with that
chip a computer scientist and hacker
named Matt Blais figured out a way to
disable the government access feature of
the chip and the whole project was
eventually abandoned and by the way is
there a more ninety series of words than
a hacker named Matt Blais it's gotta be
right up there with talk to the hand
Furby and Grammy Award winners milli
vanilli but thanks to the Clipper Chip
Fiasco and strong pressure from tech
companies the government backed off
eventually abandoning the push for a
perfect backdoor but decades later they
seem to have convinced themselves that
it can be done
I believe that Apple's capabilities are
remarkable when it is their desire I
think Silicon Valley is full of great
people who when they were younger
we're told your dreams are too hard they
were standing in a garage someplace they
were told can't be done thank goodness
they didn't listen I hate to hear talk
like that cannot be done I mean think
about if Jack Kennedy said we can't go
to the moon that cannot be done he said
something else we're gonna get there
in the next decade okay listen I love
that optimism but for the record there
are lots of things we can't do even
though we've been to the moon for
example we are yet to master time travel
or figure out why Hulk Hogan dresses for
court like he's a pallbearer at a boa
constrictors view those still elude
human understanding and to some extent
the government's faith in Apple's magic
powers is the company's own fault after
all their ads have linked them to
Einstein and Gandhi and they sell the
most mundane aspects of their products
as world changes this is iPhone 6s not
much has changed except it responds to
the pressure of your finger now you can
change apps like this pay up more places
like this and blue color looks like this
it's rose gold it's awesome
oh no it is not rose gold
looks like someone vomited a salmon
dinner onto a pair of dirty ballet shoes
but ads like those obscure the real
truth about Apple which is that beneath
their shiny rose gold surface they like
any other software company are
incredibly susceptible to hackers who
are constantly finding flaws in their
security features right now you can buy
boxes like this one on eBay that can
hack you into an iphone running some
versions of iOS 8 or lower just watch
this YouTube video showing you how they
work you just attach the wire to the
screen adjust a few settings let it
cycle through pass codes and eventually
you are in an Apple understandably do
not want us thinking too much about that
scary security flaws is one of those
three word phrases they absolutely hate
to be associated with like corporate tax
avoidance or Factory suicide Nets
also when Apple argues that if it's
forced to have access to all its
customers encrypted data it can't 100%
guarantee its safety most computer
scientists agree or as matt blazed the
guy who hacks the Clipper Chip put it
when I hear the it if we can put a man
on the moon
we can do this I'm hearing an analogy
almost as if we're saying if we can put
a man on the moon well surely we can put
a man on the Sun and that is a rational
scientific view just because a man can
walk on the moon does not mean he might
as well be walking on the Sun appoint
sunrise recently in the New England
Journal of smashmouth but look but look
for the sake of argument let's assume
Apple could have access to your
encrypted data repeatedly help law
enforcement and always keep the bad guys
out which again is widely thought by
experts to be impossible that still
won't solve the FBI's going dark problem
because if you really want to keep your
communication secret there's an app for
that the encryption debate is proven to
be good business for one startup
telegram a messaging app that encrypts
messages end-to-end has surpassed 100
million users and that's the point
people who want encryption will always
be able to find it if it's not telegram
or whatsapp it could be one of the more
than 800 other encryption products out
there almost two-thirds of which are
made by companies not easily covered by
US law like silent phone or three myrrh
or snicker tea snack or mail grub now
granted those last two aren't real but
the point is they will be in five
minutes if the government forces the
other ones to weaken their encryption
and that might not be the only
unintended consequence of the FBI's
actions many countries around the world
including Russia and China are watching
this debate and will presumably expect
similar access because as you know
Russia and China have as much respect
for privacy as horny teenagers in 80s
comedies and when you consider all this
the legal tenuous nathie FBI's case the
security risks of creating a key the
borderline impossibility of perfectly
securing the key the International
fallout of creating a precedent and the
fact that the terrorists could
circumvent all of this by downloading
whatever the freemar is
it's enough to sway the most strident
opinion case-in-point remember Lindsey
Graham mr. this is stupid
just this week three months after he
said that he was in a hearing with the
Attorney General Loretta Lynch about
this subject and this happened I think
that for us the issue is about a
criminal investigation into a terrorist
act and the need to obtain evidence and
but it's just not so simple and I'll end
with this I thought it was that simple I
was all with you until I actually
started getting briefed by people in the
Intel community and I will say I'm a
person who's been moved by the arguments
of the president we said and the damage
we may be doing to our own national
security it's a miracle
Lindsey Graham has met the concept of
nuance and this is a man who once warned
the world is literally about to blow up
so you're not dealing with someone who
likes to dabble with gray areas and look
there is no easy side to be on in this
debate strong encryption has its costs
from protecting terrorists to drug
dealers to child pornographers but I
happen to feel that the risks of
weakening encryption even a little bit
even just for the government are
potentially much worse and even though
I'm on Apple side in this case I do
think they would help both their
customers and the government understand
this a lot better if they were a little
more honest regarding security in their
ads hi we're Apple this is an Apple
iPhone it comes in rose gold it's
awesome this is an Apple customer hey
Siri find vegan sushi mmm sounds good
and these are the engineers who make our
products hey hey guys we can help you
communicate celebrate pay for stuff
everything but here's something you
should know we're barely one step ahead
of hackers at all times that when you
idiots lose your phone your information
doesn't wind up the hands of guys like
Gary hey I'm Gary
thanks for losing your phone hey
Gary because if Gary can get in he has
access to pictures of your food your
bank account pretty much everything
now I can masturbate to photos of your
family okay Gary and when we find out
there's a security flaw this is how we
react yeah that's about right so when
the FBI comes to us and asks if we can
undermine our encryption without
compromising everyone else's emails
texts and skateboarding videos this is
our response are you kidding me we're
engineers not wizards you sure you're
not wizards yeah pretty sure okay listen
Apple's not perfect you need proof we
made the Newton we made that one Mac
that looks like a toaster we actually
thought the Apple watch was cool
wait this isn't cool oh we put a u2
album on your phones you know the one
you've been struggling to delete that
thing keeps coming back huh and you
can't even make our battery less more
than like a day why is that exactly have
you tried turning off location services
and push emails and adjusting your
screen brightness so that you can okay
forget we asked the point is best-case
scenario we can keep hackers out of your
stuff for about six months before this
happens again I'm back I see someone's
been to the beach
so please keep enjoying our products
just know this shaky edifice could
crumble at any moment
Apple join us as we dance madly in the
lip of the volcano
you